bonsoir normand mousseau enfin vous avez
co présidé la commission des enjeux
énergétiques du québec en 2013 le signal
si la tendance se maintient on s'en va
au delà de 5 % pour 2023 c'est
directement lié à la décision qui avait
été prise est ce que vous pensez qu'on
devrait revenir sur cette décision là en
fait on avait fait ça parce que
historiquement il ya vu ce qu'on appelle
des écarts de rendement donc en gros on
avait évalué les revenus pour une année
d'hydro-québec les coûts pour une année
et sas avait fait en sorte que chaque
année on évaluer combien on a ça allait
coûter combien avoir de revenus puis la
régie de l'énergie donc ajuster le taux
tarifs de l'électricité pour garantir un
certain profit à hydro-québec le année
après année et il ya eu des écarts
amende et grande synthe où hydro-québec
haram a surestimé ses coûts par rapport
à ses revenus et pour faire sont à peu
près arrêté de ça on a décidé bon on va
simplifier les choses on s'en va avec
l'inflation mais l'ancien système c'est
en fonction des demandes d'hydro-québec
et des besoins sur ses coûts de
distribution voilà et c'était à la régie
c'est à dire qu'il y avait des groupes
qui fait remettre en question les
positions les analystes draw québec et
c'était discussions qui durent est quand
même quelques mois pour arriver à une
réponse quant à une décision quant aux
tarifs oui et là on la rime à
l'inflation ne choisit de le faire à
l'inflation mais pourquoi l'inflation ce
que là on a de l'inflation énergétique
on a de l'inflation sur les aliments
c'est quoi le rapport avec les besoins
d'hydro-québec en fait c'est pour qu'on
ne retourne pas en arrière puis qu'on
aille pas chercher les écarts de
rendement donc en alliant comme ça toute
efficacité gagné par hydro québec était
un gain direct pour le gouvernement
parce que tous est efficace et là en
productivité par exemple augmenter les
revenus parce que c'est une façon
finalement de ne pas avoir à rembourser
les québécois si on avait mal estimé les
revenus par examen est ce que je
comprends que le nouveau système coûte
plus cher finalement aux québécois avec
une inflation qui est galopante quand
ces métaux présents connerie tout à fait
donc ça coûte plus cher aux québécois ça
aurait coûté moins cher aux québécois en
terme de hausse tarifaire si on était
resté avec l'ancien système de régie
semblablement encore on sait pas parce
qu'on n'a pas les chiffres donc
qu'hydro-québec par faire c'était
justement le seulement aux cinq ans
depuis la loi 2019 donc on n'a pas les
chiffres depuis deux ans pour évaluer
mais si on garde historiquement c'était
en bas de l'inflation l'augmentation
alors est ce que le gouvernement doit
marcher sur la peinture
compte tenu qu'on sait pas trop le 5 6
7% d'inflation
il y avait un député de l'opposition qui
demandait à monsieur julien il ya deux
ans si on a une guerre il va se passer
quoi avec l'inflation mais on a une
guerre puis on voit l'inflation gréer ps
que le gouvernement doit reculer voire
reculer mais moi j'aurai pas de manière
arbitraire il faut ramener ça la régie
comme on l'avait mis pour évaluer
correctement dans un cas de monopole
c'est comme ça qu'on gère normalement
les coûts d'un monopole via une analyse
économique serré des coûts des revenus a
ajouté m qu'est-ce qu'on fait donc de
l'argent supplémentaire si gouvernement
dit on on garde ça comme ce système là
que doit faire hydro québec et qui vont
verser des dividendes supplémentaires on
imagine avec cet argent n'a pour moi il
ya deux choses d'abord il faut protéger
les plus affectés par cette hausse cela
donc pas l'ensemble des citoyens mais
ceux qui sont les plus affectées
devraient être protégés par des
ristournes ou des ajustements tarifs
août je laisse le soin de faire le
gouvernement de penser à ça et je serai
aussi utilisons sauf pour électrifier
pour avancer sur la transition
énergétique on le voit hydro québec
mais les freins ne veut pas vraiment
s'engager la dengue préfère confier son
voeu ses responsabilités à énergie donc
avec cet argent là on pourrait dire mon
vol prendre pour renforcer le réseau
pour faciliter l'explication du bâtiment
mais aussi de la chauffe industrielle
par exemple des procédés industriels
pour qu'on avance un peu pas beaucoup
mais au moins un peu vain nos objectifs
climatiques est il toujours clair pour
vous que nous ne payons pas cher notre
notre électricité au québec non c'est
moi je pense est une fausse façon de
regarder ça parce que quand on regarde
dans le chauffage le gaz naturel est
moins chère que l'électricité donc pour
la partie chauffage qui quand même la
partie congrue de notre facture
d'électricité on paie plus cher
si on chauffe simplement avec des
plinthes électriques comparer avec le
gaz naturel évidemment il y aurait moyen
de faire mieux en allant vers des
thermopompes des choses comme ça qu'ils
vont réduire notre demande d'électricité
pour le même service de chaleur donc on
près équilibré mais pour le moment c'est
pas vrai qu'on paye pas ses chers parce
que et hydro québec il le ministre de
l'énergie nous nous sommes on nous
présente toujours des graphiques où on
voit qu'on qu'à montréal par exemple on
paie beaucoup moins cher qu'ailleurs
l'électricité mais le problème c'est
qu'en mer on chauffe à l'électricité
donc on paye pas cette électrice et le
canton et en ontario où une électricité
beaucoup plus chère qu'au québec sauf
que personne ou presque ils chauffent à
l'électricité
on utilise du gaz naturel et la facture
de chauffage est donc plus faible qu'au
québec c'est pas je dis pas ça pour
défendre le gaz naturel
est ce qu'on s'en va est-ce qu'il est
clair pour vous qu'on s'en va vers une
hausse record sur l'addition des
passions net à 5 6 7% je veux pas lancer
des chiffres mais au moins 1 5% c'est
probablement dans les grosses qu'on ne
le dit pas regarder le historiquement
toutes les hausses que chez hydro québec
mais c'est certainement très élevé ok
normal ou sur merci d'avoir été avec moi
c'est un plaisir c'est beaucoup pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]